what are you telling him now only what
the little Lord wants to hear okay
you're super I want some time with him
one time she told me the sky is blue
because we live inside the eye of a
blue-eyed giant named Macomber maybe we
do would you like to sit no thank you
someone no thank you I'm sorry about
your grandson I I don't believe that a
child is responsible for the sins of his
father or his grandfather an awful way
to die which way is that
by your irrigating me Lord Tywin
somebody if King choked some believe the
sky is blue because we live inside the
eye of a blue-eyed giant what's up
ladies and gentlemen how you doing today
by now most of you should know that Game
of Thrones released their official promo
for their seventh season yesterday which
caused a frenzy in the Game of Thrones
community one of the hottest debates
that came from this perma was about the
blue eye that was shown at the end of
the promo again but before we get into
this discussion I just want to preface
it by saying that I definitely think
this is the night King's eye from
yesterday's promo because some people
might get my opinion confused with what
I said about the last teaser but when I
first watched the promo yesterday the
first thing that came to my mind was
well that's obviously the night Kings
eye this time but after looking at it
again I thought damn that nose looked
awfully big almost too big to be the
night Kings eye because at the time I
didn't realize what the actual size of
the make Kings nose was so after
watching the promo a few times and going
to Twitter to get a second opinion I did
start to think [ __ ] maybe that is the
giant sign then it seems like almost
everyone was saying the exact same thing
yesterday I made a promo breakdown video
and when I looked at the comments on
that video over 50% of you seem to
believe that the blue eye from the new
promo is definitely a giant sigh and
after reading dozens and dozens of
comments saying this I figured there's
only one way to find out let's examine
the eye and nose from the promo and
let's examine the eye in the nose of the
night King and a giant when I first
compared the image with the endings of a
giant they do look very similar both
noses are very big with wrinkles in the
part of the eyebrow that connects with
the bridge of the nose does drop down
over the eye a little bit so I can
definitely see why people would believe
this at first glance there isn't a whole
lot to go off of the image that was
shown in the promo because it only shows
a small portion of the face which is
exactly what HBO wanted to do because
they knew everybody would talk about
this because it could be a number of
characters honestly but when you start
to compare the features to the features
of the night king you can clearly see
that it's the same person so let's take
a look the night King actually has the
biggest nose much bigger than I thought
he did when I was just going off of the
image that I had in mind
but if you look closely you can see that
the night Kings brow does drop down over
the eye just like the one from the promo
and if you look at the bridge of the
Night Kings nose there are two wrinkles
or creases which is exactly what we see
in the promo and if you look at the
bridge of the nose from the Giant you
can see that he only has one big crease
or wrinkle there which doesn't match up
the same with the one from the promo
because you can see the nose from the
promo clearly has two wrinkles which
isn't the same for the Giant and if you
look at the bottom of the nose by the
nostrils you can see that the making has
those same wrinkles too plus around the
eye is very dark almost black just like
to make Kings personally after looking
at it this way I think it's definitely
the knight Kings face in the promo I
completely understand why people would
think it was a Giants though because
even I started to second-guess it at
first because there are some
similarities when you look at it but
when you're looking at a close
like this the nose is obviously going to
look much much larger than it actually
is you also have to remember what this
perma was about in the theme of it Plus
who was featured in it it was a king and
queen affair so it wouldn't make much
sense for them to show the giant here in
my opinion and he also had to think
where the hell would the night King get
a giant there were only a few left and
we saw those ones die and we know the
wildlings would never leave a body
laying around without burning it they
know exactly what the night king is
capable of and how dangerous a giant
white would be so I highly doubt they
would give the 19 an opportunity to get
a giant on their team but these are just
my opinions those photos in comparisons
aren't concrete evidence so I understand
if you still disagree but comment below
though and give me your thoughts after
seeing the photos of the giant and the
night King side-by-side to the eye and
the nose from the promo who's I do you
think it is I say it's the night king
but let me know if you change your mind
about what you originally thought it was
but before you guys go I have a few
recommendations for you if any of you
love watching youtube videos as much as
I do especially about Game of Thrones or
A Song of Ice and Fire then there are
some channels you should definitely
check out because they make some great
videos too and most of these channels
made some amazing breakdown videos
yesterday first I want to shout out
secrets of the Citadel most of you
should know who she is by now she has an
amazing channel with plenty of videos
for you to go and enjoy she does these
really great in-depth videos about
pretty much anything a Song of Ice and
Fire related plus she did a brilliant
promo breakdown yesterday she was the
first person I saw that really broke
down the lyrics from the song they used
for the teaser and also this should go
without saying go check out my man
smokescreens channel you should know by
now he's one of my favorite youtubers
he's always releasing videos just like
secrets of the Citadel they're always
putting out something for us to watch
and learn from there are also really
nice people to who deserve all the
praise in a room but before our ramble
your Dan ears off let me get out of here
don't forget to check out these other
great channels as well that I have
shouted out in my previous videos before
except for Britt who deserves her own
shout out video because of how
supportive she's been since the very
beginning anyways comment below tell me
whose eye that is and I will see you
down in the comment section bye